the first time I'm giving a talk with a
clicker it's a very exciting moment for
me I'm going to talk to you today about
a project I did at work in which I found
movie reviews on radio shows and
podcasts so before I start telling you
about my project I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the company for which I
work audio bursts that other than having
pink branding we also do things okay so
what we do is we create a new listening
experience for radio in podcasts what we
are trying to do is to take out the
essence out of radio shows and podcasts
into shorts into short stories to which
we call bursts it's in the name and and
then you can just listen to what's
interesting you don't need to listen to
a three hours podcast in order to
understand what are the interesting
three things that were talked about so
this is what we do we listen to a lot a
lot of data over 400 radio stations and
over 4,000 pod podcasts we analyze this
data meaning that we need to understand
what is being said who is talking what
they're talking about what's currently
happening in the world and then we
deliver bursts here is it with a little
bit more information so we actually
listen to all these all these
interesting sources live radio podcasts
and other talk media and we analyze it
by doing the transcription extracting
out NLP NLP info and also a audio cues
and then we cut it into bursts this a
stage is harder than it look it then it
looks obviously because we both need to
segment this data and we want to in
music and we want to remove
advertisements and then all this data
goes into our audio content repository
and why it's still the time when a user
wants to hear something out of it then
the user shows up he can show either by
calling us from his phone or by
searching on a website or by searching
from his car
this a user wants something when we are
under strong to understand what it is
that he wants what's the intent of the
user at this point we also use of course
all sorts of NLP tours here to
understand what he wants and we give him
a personalized the best all playlist oh
what it was that he was looking for okay
so at this point I want you to be
convinced that we have a lot of
interesting challenges at audio burst
and I'm going to tell you oh wait and
this is a yes and this is our this is a
screenshot I took from our website in
which you can see that you can either
search or use one of our predefined
playlists in a topic that you like oh
you can use you can listen to a
personalized playlist that suits your
own needs
okay so now to my project so the project
I'm going to talk about today is the
some sort of a niche project and that we
did on movie reviews and what we wanted
to achieve is that our users will be
able to go online and ask for a movie
review about a certain movie and get a
movie review why is this interesting and
well when you listen to something you
don't only listen what you don't only
hear what someone thought about the
movie you get the entire experience you
can hear it in his voice if he was
excited yes or no what he actually
thought maybe he's he's like discussing
with someone else about this movie it's
a whole new experience when we wanted to
bring it so um I'm going to tell about
the different stages at this project so
at first what we did is exploring we
have this huge audio repository I own
which I told you and we just used it to
search for bells talking about movies we
took a list of movies we searched and we
listened and then we started to
understand how does it even sound how
does a movie review on the radio sound
what are they talking about also we
wanted to understand what else is out
there and we realized that there are a
lot of other things about movies that
are not reviews for example how did this
movie did on the cashier
and what sort of problems well in the in
the movie production or any other
information at this point we decided to
try and understand if a certain burst I
remind you a short audio clip talking
about something is a review yes oh no
for this and we wanted a we decided to
build a classifier yeah okay so we
created a test set I'm out of our own
data and we decided to classify whether
a movie review whether a best I'm sorry
is a movie review yes
oh no so because we don't have tag data
this is because what we're doing is
being done for the first time what we
did is we called around and searched for
tag data of course the tag data we found
was a text and not audio and it's
different from there from the data we
have because the data we have is
transcript M but anyway we tried and it
worked so we had yes so we had a
classifier that was able to tell us
whether or not a certain best is a
review okay at this point what we wanted
to do is to combine this classifier into
a product in order to have a walking
flow end-to-end that can bring us to a
stage where someone can look for a movie
review and find it so we started
thinking about how we're going to do it
so we are not going to and look for all
the movie reviews out of all the bests
why are we are we not going to do it
first of all we are searching for all
kinds of things as I told you before we
want to know if something is an idea so
know if is it a song yes or no and all
kinds of other things we're not going to
take a huge amount of data and use a
classifier to classify whether or not
it's a movie review also the small arrow
we have on our classifier because it's
not perfect I'm sorry to disappoint
everyone here and the small arrow we're
going to have is going to become a huge
problem if we are going to take tens of
thousands of birds today and and they
ask our classifier whether or not it's a
movie review
so we are giving a prequel and but what
we can do is we can ask whether or not a
whether or not a best that we found is
actually a movie review okay
so what we are going to do next is we're
going to take a candidate best that we
suspect our movie reviews and check
whether or not they are movie reviews
so let's find those candidates so what
we wanted to do is we wanted to find
movie names for which we are going to
search for bursts remember what I told
you before about the exploit we are
going to search movie names on our
system some of the scores from which I
will be able to get movie names all the
time so I can take all the movies that
were released but there are many movies
that were released here you can see just
the list of the movies that are released
on like the next two days or something
now let's have a small experiment and
who here knows Avengers held of Avengers
okay a lot of people who here held of
Bell box some of you and who here held
of zombie child no one okay so
conclusion not all movies are
interesting okay so we want to find the
movies that people are actually talking
about right now so at this point what we
did is we assumed an assumption that is
if someone in if someone's talking about
something online or if a few people are
talking about something online it's
probably also talked on on the radio or
podcasts so what we did is we started
following is we started following you
RSS feeds of reviewers so in our SAS
feed which you can see here obviously
just it's not going to okay on the
camera but it is very clear here to
everyone in the room yes exactly it's
the human eye so M so analysis is like a
subscription you can subscribe to a
certain blog or a website or a company
and to get its pushed Khan content
whenever
a new content shows up the huge
advantage of RSS feed is that they are
very easy to palace so if I'm going to
follow a few reviewers and a new and the
reviewer published something new I will
be able to very easily get this
information okay so here is how it's
done on Python here you can see a
library called feed parser and we are
extracting the first title out of the
RSS feed pastor of 9gag that you can see
here if anyone wants the details
afterwards please come and find me this
is just like I did it so that everyone
will have to come and talk to me after
the after the talk ok so at this point
we had we had our movie name okay and we
were able to go and search on our
repository for bells regarding those
movies but then we encounter encountered
a new problem when we searched for it
for Avengers we got bursts with the word
Avengers in and they were talking about
the movie but when we were searching the
movie us we found a lot of bursts as I
mentioned before we have a huge
repository of many many bells so if we
are going to look for something and our
search won't be very very specific we
are going to get a lot of junk so at
this point what we did was augmenting
our queries how did we do it we used all
kind of available data we could find
about those movies online either using
RSS feeds
I don't I showed you before oh using
available M databases online okay so at
this point we are very happy because we
already have movie names to find
candidates and we have a classifier that
is able to tell us whether or not M our
our burst is a review and indeed we
found very very very amazing reviews
regarding Aquaman and we were very happy
but we found those reviews when we were
looking for movies about Mary Poppins
I assume you all know that but in case
you don't Aquaman and Mary Poppins were
released next to each other so when
often when someone was talking about
Aquaman he was talking right afterwards
about Mary Poppins oh the opposite so
when I was looking for a belt regarding
Aquaman I found the best regarding Mary
Poppins of course I find this best and I
did it very and I did a very good job at
like shaping it and give a very good
review about the manga movie so we added
another stage in this stage we wanted to
take the reviews we found okay well at
this point very pretty sure that they
are reviews and we also listen to them
so we know it and and we we wanted to
make it better we wanted to be able to
give em to give a the actual review the
talks about the movie we want so we
added a matching process we did two
things at this stage the first thing was
to go back to our search and refine it
if any movie that was like super unknown
sneaked inside we removed it or if
anything I don't know from sometimes you
have two movies I know a lot of out
movies now and if there are two movies
released yield after year or a or two
years apart
we can find the different we can find
information regarding the wrong movie
which will again enter noise into the
system we don't want that so we refine
the search the second thing we did is we
scored em the best em according to its
relevance to a certain movie hey here is
an example and what you see here is a
part of a best okay it's just a a
transcript but not the entire Belle's
just a part here you can see em entities
extracted from the best by us you're
going to have to believe me as to what
it say and the bigger the circle is the
bigger the entity is inside the best can
here you can see information regarding a
movie so the movie that you see
information here is a called late night
okay and here you
can see the the best and the entities so
I can tell you that this huge entity is
small and indeed the main character in
this a in this movie is named Mally
other than that we have here Emma
Thompson Emma Thompson is one of the two
main main actors and we also have here
Amazon Studios who produced this movie
so we can use the connections between
the entities found in the best and what
we know about the movie to understand
whether or not M the movie M is matched
okay so at this point where we ran out
of place so you can tell they stay well
done we are able to find candidate we
are able to tell whether or not a
candidate is a movie review and we are
able to say to be pretty certain about
what movie is discussed on this level
okay so here's what we did and we
started by exploring we then created a
classifier which is something we love to
do but sometimes it's just not enough
and then we created the flow to use this
classifier in the best way that will
create it that will create a product and
not just a classifier and aborting an
example that actually I wanted to show
earlier but I forgot so here is there
just one review you can search it I'll
show you long Charlize Theron Seth Rogen
right O'Shea Jackson
that's ice cubes kid and Andy Serkis so
in this film Charlize is Secretary of
State after hiring Seth Rogen as her
speechwriter
okay so now they're talking about the
movie I'll run it forward a little bit
because the body got the laser arm this
guy is a chameleon I had no idea that
some Gollum and Caesar
that's told me just told me there's
about 20 minutes ago so I saw he was
incredible he's like what's a so this is
actually a very good movie review it
starts by them telling us about the
movie telling us about the plot then
there are a few people talking about a
the movie and what they thought about it
and then they're like yes Seth Rogen is
becoming better and better as years go
by and then it's like if it's going to a
whole different direction when they
start talking about whether or not the
relationship between Charlize Theron and
Seth Rogen on the movie is sustainable
yes or no so whoever wants to hear the
entire thing is more than welcome to
come and talk to me afterwards so a
little bit about what's next and what we
can do with what we did so first of all
we now have we know a lot about movie
reviews what we did is we went to our
entire repository and search for movie
reviews and not only took like the five
six 6,600 podcasts that we know that
talk about Hollywood this allows us to
get to know better our data and to know
well this kind of data can be found
other than that of course we can know
more things about the reviews themselves
is it a good review is it a bad review
maybe we want to give the user a few
different reviews giving different
perspectives other than that this flow
can be used to do also other things we
can I don't know change the classifier
and change the domain and we have a flow
that can be used to other things as well
and now questions the question was are
we only working with English so the
movie reviews project was done on
English and we work mostly in English
but we only work in Japanese right now
and we are expanding to other languages
so yes yes you label this for spoilers
no but it's a good idea because there
it's like a huge thing we're like we're
working on data from the USA and they're
very like the spoiler thing is like is
an issue all over the world
um yes I'm just whether or not I can
apply the same flow to a different
domain so I believe that with the right
classifier yes but I can tell you for
example that I try to do the same things
for series I took the exact same flow
and I said okay it shouldn't be too hard
but then like when
first of all the there are not the same
amount of content regarding those
domains and on Ceres for example they're
more talking about episodes and less
about like the actors and like less
about that's about is it a drama is it a
comedy also all sorts of other things
but I believe that this flow can be
applied to other domains with the right
classifier yet because bursts yeah model
exactly like you have a few different
learning engineering after points one
from translating from sound to tax but
then summation of text in dance I want
to just go back to the psalm and take a
snapshot of the sound while I guess what
well so as I said we both yeah we have
transcript which transit transcript just
gives you like the word what's being
said other than that we have like models
extracting audio cues like we want to
know whether it's a female speaker or a
male speaker or whether is it like is
there music playing around and then we
combine this data it's like there's no
third model doing though of it the same
we just combine the data from the
different models normal voice we have
that yeah we have the the cue of the
data actually the transcript is less is
less than my domain although I do want
it to be a summation of the text people
actually a sensational
when you say summation 3-minute the
bell--the
oh the best is audio it's just audio
segmented so we segmented the
segmentation is done automatically and
with some when someone is searching we
want to give him like a burst
that's like cut perfectly for what he
wanted
good actually there are there are a lot
of feature and not all of them I did but
um but we try to understand if it like
if it starts is the starting reasonable
does the style seem reasonable to us if
there is an ad in the middle if there is
like I don't know a song in a bit in the
middle we have using the client some of
the some of what we have is like has
been listened but most of it is just
automatic if you're going to try and
like go to audio burst and I can show
later to whoever wants how to do it you
can go to you can go to Google assistant
and ask talk to audio burst and then you
can just ask question ask what can you
tell me about Donald Tom ask a can you
tell me the weather in New York
understand I'm asking about the of
course the algorithm need to keep
learning to get better at doing better
bursts yes
do you take an ex-friend understand now
you are ranking each birth and don't
knowing if the algorithm doing a better
job or worse job and I asked the last
question if you let it let the client
order the listener to rank at the end to
say I like this I think it is a good
personal if you will look at the Google
assistant you will see that now we don't
do it but I believe that soon we will
yeah definitely so there are a lot of
different problems here like we need the
segmentation to be interesting we need
the birds to be interesting we needed to
start in an interesting way that will
make the listener keep listening so I
believe it will be pretty hard even
though we might collect this data in the
future it will be very hard to
understand why someone ranked 1 or 5
stars unless we have like huge amounts
of data thank you
[Applause]